happy tuesday everyone
first we have to acknowledge acknowledge
the great news it's great news for you
and me and all of america frankly
yes larry kudlow's
back didn't think we could do it but
there you are it took months of hard
work lots of hot tubbing but he's here
i'm not proud of some of the things i
had to do in that tub larry
but i'll do whatever it takes
also side note al qaeda leader al-zawari
was killed
you're sick
he was just 71 years young
his remains will be cremated and spread
over his already cremated remains
and to think he just finished paying off
his women's studies degree
we went to his family for comment
[Music]
that's terrible show the guy some
respect let's go to his real family
[Applause]
you know that's even worse you know how
those guys hate pork
it's the other white meat they despise
no wonder he became a terrorist at least
he didn't get into stripping because
once the robe comes off it's just ankle
socks
don't ask me how i know
so when i first heard the news i have to
say i was a little confused and no
that's not a quote from the president
first i had not heard that name in a
while
like chris wallace
but it was
but it was a name i literally heard or
wrote about every day for a period of
years after 9 11 but for some reason we
stopped hearing about him and also
stopped talking much about islamic
terror especially after trump got in
remember isis and those videos
we should that was bad so when the news
broke yesterday during the five it was
if my terror muscles were flabby i
hadn't used them in so long unlike my
actual quads that went a blue ribbon at
that wine festival
thanks larry for taking me
but the terror muscles they were rusty i
imagine it's how the view panelists feel
about their brains
but i realized i needed to get back in
shape quick the killing is a helpful
reminder that terror like smallpox and
chris cuomo never really goes away
especially when 911 plotters have
assistants like the taliban i had no
idea he was in afghanistan hanging with
the taliban and not in a good way at the
end of a rope
but turns out he was staying at a house
apparently belonging to afghan deputy
interior minister and new york times
contributor siri judean haqqani
and it's not a bad place to die
you know it's amazing what you can get
from
airbnb although i don't think the owner
will be too happy about the condition
the guests left the place in
that cleaning bill is gonna suck
how do you get bone matter out of the
formica
i know too soon right
but take a look the place had a balcony
it had great views and now thanks to a
hellfire missile it's got an open-air
kitchen
[Applause]
what
with 72 virgins cooking in it
yeah huh you'll wish you died and gone
to heaven
but let's show a picture of the dead guy
yep that's definitely al zahuari
or as merrick garland calls him a white
supremacist
if you'll notice his red hat is under
the turban
of course this raises some questions is
afghanistan going back to being a base
of operations of terrorists seems so
which means like jlo and ben affleck
al-qaeda and the taliban are reunited
it feels so bad
i'm just a little nervous we whacked
this guy and meanwhile thanks to the
joe's open borders policy there have
been confirmed reports of anywhere from
50 to 100 people in the terror watch
list unaccounted for in our country
right now
but still this is good news that we
killed him because it means we can pick
off the people we need to pick off
without waging full-blown wars and any
day when a terrorist dies is a good day
in my book of course when you kill a
terrorist another one takes its place
you know in a way it's just like
cancelled late-night talk shows
terrible
one flops and there are three worst ones
waiting in the wings
you didn't think i could make that
analogy did you but i did and that's why
i get paid the big bucks
those are some big bucks
don't be so sad i'll be home soon fellas
just save some acorns and apples for me
now some people don't want to credit
biden since after all he said al qaeda
was no threat in afghanistan
what interest do we have in afghanistan
at this point with al-qaeda gone
we went to afghanistan for the express
purpose of getting rid of al-qaeda in
afghanistan as well as as well as
getting osama bin laden
and we did
so like my aunt who eats plastic army
men
biden's claims have not aged well
it appears al qaeda was there and were
active and out in the open like a cold
sore on a spring breaker's lip
i hope it was a cold sore
not monkey pox
by the way what was i doing with her and
i think we can be skeptical about how
much biden really knew about any of this
since like a rare mushroom he's kept in
the dark on everything he's basically
living in a non-stop blackout
like son like father
for him every day
how does that get applause
for him every day starts out as a blank
slate and someone comes in and adds the
daily specials i guess what i'm trying
to say is his brains are creamed spinach
and corn chowder
and remember this guy did take a victory
lap after we got bin laden after saying
he was against taking him out that's
like me taking credit for taylor swift's
success when i had nothing to do with it
i mean true we dated and everything
and her biggest hit shake it off was
about me stubbing my toe on her bed post
but unlike her i'll leave the dirty
laundry to cat's office
but still when bad things happen under a
president they get the blame and when
good things happen under a president
they get the credit the problem with joe
however is he won't take the
responsibility for the disasters so it's
hard for me to give him a slap on the
back over this but what the hell
i will anyone anyway nice one joe
but really it's our american forces who
get the accolades it's the players who
win the world series not the manager
especially one who can't find his way
out of the locker room
so job well done guys and gals you sent
a hellish monster straight to hell in
tiny little packages i wish it could
have been sooner but i say that about
everything including 2024.
[Applause]
tonight's guess
he puts the fine in finance host of
kudlow and fox business sexy larry
kudlow
[Applause]
she's one badass broad caster host of
sunny's corner on siriusxm patriot sonny
johnson
[Applause]
she found her cat in a dumpster or vice
versa fox news contributor cat tiff
and his jumping jacks require special
clearance from the faa my massive
sidekick in the nwa world television
champion tyrus
larry this is good news but you care to
expand on your own perspective on this i
thought you did a very good job thank
you really it did a very good job and we
should never forget 9 11 and how bad
that was and zawahiri was a key planner
so you're dead right on all counts and
i'm glad they got him um
no hell is good enough for that son of a
[ __ ] right would you say that
tip tip of the hat to joe biden
especially tip of the hat to the
intelligence services who really
engineered this
and i'll just having said that
i'll issue a warning because you
mentioned it the fact is taliban is
harboring al-qaedas or haqqanis okay
the second fact is
we still have not made good on our
afghanistan promises to help all those
american friends and allies who are
still there stuck in that despotic
country and actually something mike
pompeo said to me on our show today
american taxpayers should not give one
nickel to this taliban regime they are
terrorists they hate america they hate
freedom they hate all our values so
good so
as i hear he's gone but we've got to
keep our guard up all the time because
they're coming after us you know um that
leads me to a probably an obvious
follow-up question how did mike pompeo
lose all that weight
right
i hate to be a spokesperson
but i think he ate less
i hear that works
i hear that works that's not good i just
came up with that i thought that was
that very very natural you're doing good
kid
i was completely unprepared it wasn't in
the notes
sunny always great to see you
what's your take on all this
um i feel bad laughing at so many of
jokes at the beginning
so um
but i guess appropriate for greg
put that out there um
one of the things that i think is most
dangerous about
zawahiri dying is if you listen to what
everyone says they say that the main
thing about him was he didn't have the
cult of personality that bin laden had
right so that's what scares me more than
anything that the next one that comes
after him is going to not only have the
murderous ideology but is also going to
have the personality to push it and i
say i think that that might be a reason
why we haven't heard so much about it in
the last couple of years but if they get
the right face and the right voice out
there to be in leadership of what
they're doing then i think we're really
going to you know hear a lot more coming
out of afghanistan but if you think
about it in terms of
our politicians here pushed us into
globalism thinking like this was going
to be
um the answer to what else us here in
america and part of that was the war on
terror and now what we're seeing is the
east isn't participating in our
globalism africa isn't participating in
our globalism south america isn't
participating in our globalism so it's
not globalism it's just westernism and a
shout out to hotep jesus for saying it
on my show but um that's where we are
now is that we are coming to a
realization that as a nation we have
been pushed into this idea of
globalization and it's like we're the
only kid at the birthday party like
nobody else is showing up yeah and it's
going to be very sad when we go to open
the presents and and we realize exactly
what's there in terms of lost treasure
in terms of lost our lives in terms of
lost stature across the world yeah
that's where we are and they want to
call us isolationists for pointing that
out no y'all did a very good job of
isolating us on your own we had nothing
to do with that that's a brilliant point
the point especially the point about the
the absence the absence of
alzheimer's being due to his personality
cat you're an expert at getting bombed
[Laughter]
apparently you'll never get tired of
this i know i know um oh it gets worse
as the show goes on cat i just want to
warn you a little trigger warning there
was a libertarian are you okay with this
oh no i i i am certainly not
the terrorist should live
like what kind of question is that
okay yeah i'm going to blow your mind
here i think the terrorists bad
[Music]
9 11 was also bad good job yeah you tell
me you did 9 11. i'm going to say no sir
that was not good excellent good job
well how many would you expect me to do
some kind of nuanced take on this
i was just thinking if you had like a
little you know some kind of like uh
complexity having to do with you know
missiles and things i don't know what
you libertarians think
well
we think we are not pro-terrorists right
that's good
all right well you learned something new
about me today
tyrus all right wrap it up for us
with your thoughtful
uh you know i'm i'm gonna be the bad guy
here i guess i'll be the the cat in this
situation
my i'm concerned about the point of this
you spit in the face of all the allies
we had in afghanistan you left them
hanging you empowered the bad guys
you china's punking us russia's punking
us and you go and kill the quiet guy
that everyone forgot about it was
powerless
so now you just inspired everyone who
needed an excuse
for martyrdom that's what that's the
problem with this administration we
can't even nancy pelosi has to
fly to taiwan like i'm going and our
administration looks like i don't know i
probably wouldn't go i don't know
china is bigger than us and
that's our administration
if our previous administration if
someone would have made a threat like
that to pelosi they've been like for
every plane i see there'll be 500 of
ours and a bomb you know it would have
been a threat no one would talk to the
united states that way afghanistan
wouldn't think about the things that
we've done but we continue to make these
horrible mistakes these gaffes so you
you pissed it down your leg in
afghanistan and now you went and you
gave them a martyr so i'm not as
thrilled about it i'm glad he's dead but
i i just think the timing was pathetic
and it's not going to take our minds off
inflation what horrible what you're
doing under education with our police no
nothing that's going to work no smoke
screen is going to work so you killed a
guy who was ineffective at the top yeah
so you've inspired a bunch of new guys
and we have an open border yeah yeah
well played
like
it tastes like
statistically speaking a lot of the
times when you take someone out
something like that the lower level
people who replace them are even more
ruthless but the tiniest thing that was
taken out
i thought this was one deal yet that's i
mean sonny's point that like if they get
a charismatic leader again then all bets
are off hey sean hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to fox news youtube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere else